you know cancel culture has gotten bad
for Democrats that even top liberal
leaders are getting worried about it
former president Barack Obama blasting
woke Democrats in his party and telling
them to stop being a quote buzzkill
people just want to not feel as if
they are
walking on eggshells we're going around
scolding folks if they don't use exactly
the right phrase or you know that
identity politics becomes the principal
lens through which we View
our our various political
uh challenges
the former president not stopping there
with his critiques of the democratic
party Obama also telling Democrats to
stop obsessing over Trump
we spend enormous amounts of time and
energy and resources pointing out the
latest crazy thing he said or uh you
know the how rude or mean you know some
of these Republican candidates behaved
that's probably not something that that
um
in the minds of most voters override
their basic interests
so Greg is the former president spot on
oh absolutely but it's I mean he's a
little late to the party exactly I mean
I we should be grateful that he finally
showed up but if he had gotten in early
on that's you know before wokeism took
over we would still have Roseanne we
might still have cops Pee-wee Herman
would still have a morning show but no
we had to wait until everybody got
canceled uh I know but it's hard to be
Obama because if he says the moment he
expresses this stuff they're gonna crap
all over him for sounding like us right
but he used the right word which was
buzz kill you have to look at wokism in
cancer culture as an attack on fun you
know we talk about this show and my show
and maybe Jesse's I don't know but we
flipped this we flipped the script right
it was always the right that we're
humorless and stayed and it was the left
that was Animal House what's happened
now it's a complete reverse you could
tell Republicans conservatives
Libertarians they're the ones that are
having fun they're the ones that are pro
are for drug legalization and they're
the ones that don't you know they don't
they want to have a party they don't
care what you wear at the party right
and now the Democrats or the left or
what's within the Democrat is are
they're now the fallwells and the
Phyllis athletes of the two the 2022
they've become the humorless dean
wormers and we're now Animal House
that's what he recognizes and that's
what it would be very helpful if you
pointed out you guys you young liberals
you got to have more fun you look so
miserable pouring milk out at stores and
screaming at people on the street nobody
wants to be around you on Thanksgiving
you're miserable go to the gym clean up
sorry all right Dana what about the fact
that uh when when Joe Biden came out
with the Maga the whole maggot thing and
now former president Obama says stop
obsessing over Trump I mean is is that
kind of an attack against Biden as well
is there something going on there that's
pretty interesting because I hadn't
thought of it that way I think that
could be sure because I I believe that
especially through this particular
podcast they try to give the White House
advice uh and If Only They had listened
to them right and those are the Obama
people trying to tell the Biden people
what to do and there is friction there
but I don't think Obama is wrong uh he
had said something similar to this
before but mostly about college debates
remember he came out and said you got to
have a place where you can have a free
flow of ideas and he tried to do that
but if you think back do you remember
when he was first in office they got a
rodeo clown fired that's right for
wearing an Obama mask and that rodeo
clown had worn the mask of every
previous president that's just what you
did so it almost would have been
offensive if the road audio clown had
not done it but instead what they did is
they ran that guy out of town and he
didn't even have a job think about to
the Beer Summit why did we have to have
the beer Summit that was also something
like that and then he says something
like this in Georgia what on the Senate
side Rafael Warnock is going around and
talking about all these things regarding
identity politics but he and Stacy
Abrams were the ones that ran the Major
League Baseball out of town and
according to some people on the ground
there's still a lot of hurt feelings
over that and people haven't forgotten
that so yes welcome but maybe a little
too late yeah Jesse what about the fact
that it is too late why now
he's probably thinking these woke losers
are going to get crushed in the midterm
so I want to put some distance between
myself and the Democratic party and say
see I told you show that that that's
because he's always about himself you
know he's always like well I know how to
win and he didn't know how to win yeah
but he also got his party crushed in
both midterms and gave us Trump he can't
see he can't say he was against identity
politics he's the first black president
his historic first black president you
remember he took it to the bitter
clingers
talk about beer Summit but we had all
that stuff that was the whole anti-cup
thing it started there it started under
Barack Obama anytime you attacked the
Affordable Care Act it was because you
were racist he he did that all the time
don't act like this thing just started
it gave birth during the Barack Obama
years and it also is this he's getting
older Michelle's getting older
Sasha and Malia are coming home they're
annoying their boyfriends probably are
annoying they're saying dad stop
misgendering people you can't say that
Dad and they're rolling their eyes at
these people they're Barry's out on the
golf course they're all out on the golf
course whether it's Nancy I don't know
if she doesn't play golf They Roll their
eyes at the buzz kills they don't
understand the non-binary
intersectionality colonize their mindset
they don't get that at all but they're
afraid to say it and he's trying to say
it's okay guys you can move out of this
stuff this is how you do it but Greg was
right we could have used them when they
were tearing down statues of Columbus
yeah no question no question and you
know Jessica I mean what you've got is
very few Democrats dared cross that
Rubicon and say you know this wokeness
is for the birds but James Carville did
a long time ago and but nobody seemed to
follow him why well James Carville has
given no F's for decades that's his
brand and that's what he's really good
at and obviously with seminal an
incredibly successful 1990s and getting
us through a huge Wipeout of losing the
house and then contract for America and
all of it
um people do listen to James Carville
they don't necessarily have the cable
news pundit jobs right they're not the
ones who are in your face all day
they're not on the editorial page of the
New York Times but they're out there and
what President Obama is doing that's
different than other people who
criticize it he's criticizing liberals
he's not talking about conservatives
he's talking about liberals who make it
impossible for you to Breathe Right This
is the whole like the term latinx which
three percent of Hispanics in this
country actually use I've been in so
many meetings looking at PowerPoint
presentations and they say and to reach
the latinx community I work in research
who is that yeah right what is that and
that's liberal on liberal problems if
you want to say whatever you want about
Republicans try to make it as polite as
possible I get it but some of this woke
stuff is alienating I is a moderate to
conservative Democrats certainly
Independents and I'm sure that that
Loops back to what's going on with
Independent Women and then moderate
Republicans who do hate Donald Trump
when Obama says don't talk about it in
him anymore the perception of Donald
Trump has been baked in I'd say since
about 20 minutes after after he came
down that golden escalator people knew
exactly what they thought of him and
that has not changed since then so yes
leaving that aside especially when the
midterms are kitchen table issue
elections we know what they want to talk
about inflation the economy crime and
Public Safety
um I'll just say every time he shows up
I say this he's a wonderful asset for
the party I wish that he and Michelle
would do more they're only going to
three spots I think I don't know if
that's about tension would the Biden
camp or not but we need voices like that
Bill Clinton's the same he just shoots
it straight and he says stop doing this
do that and we would do much better hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know sure
that you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now